straight my day junkie block my night
all day this one coming up is an animal
yeah where Cormier and John Jones yeah
I'm exciting [ __ ] thing is how do I
go yeah okay ha dude you're the man
hooked up that's it [ __ ] mm right
next to me my dad's gonna be in town -
my dad oh dude do I'll give you two
tickets one for your dad ah [ __ ] cool
you and your dad I want to meet your dad
I want to buy your last store when
you're 13 you went to motley crue with
them my dad God's doing that man I
wouldn't even be a priority for him I
don't think that's all so I'm not great
that's cool
ah Jim so excited I wanted to ask to
like you know Father [ __ ] talking people
had to promote the fight you know but
like Daniel Cormier and John Jones no
matter who wins the end of the fight
they're going to shake each other's
hands right I hope so it also is it
common like what we saw with Ronda
Rousey not shaking me [ __ ] how do you
have like an armbar somebody they tap
out then they get up and go to shake
your hand and you won't do it like that
well I think that mentality that Rhonda
has is like a she's a like she's
mercenary in there I mean and it wasn't
over when it was over to her for her
wasn't a competition it was life it was
his life or death I don't know man I
mean that same thing is probably why
she's not fighting anymore you know like
her animosity and her emotions were so
riding on that thing and then when she
lost and then when she lost again in
devastating fashion that's also the
reason why there was so much backlash
whereas oh right who's really loved like
Randy Couture Randy Couture would lose a
fight and no one talked I mean I'm sure
someone talked trash about him but no
one's opinion of him differed when he
lost because he's such a good guy
and because when when he won you know
after the fight he would always pick the
guy up and shake their hand and hug them
and he was always a gentleman and when
people have that sort of a mentality you
know like here's a perfect example this
past weekend Dustin Poirier and Eddie
Alvarez had a fight the fight was
stopped because of an illegal blow that
Eddie Alvarez accidentally landed on
Dustin Poirier and the crowd was booing
Eddie Alvarez and Dustin Poirier yell
the crowd don't boo this man like we
were in a fight and he's not a dirty
fighter and he made a mistake and they
had first of all Eddie Alvarez I was
closed he could barely see
he was completely on queer Street he had
been almost knocked unconscious any-any
hit this dude in the clinch with a
couple of knees and the referee didn't
stop him and he thought they were legal
you know he's in the chaos of a crazy
cage fight but to have those two dudes
after the fight both are bloody and
battered both of them are just like
exhausted from a war right and I'm
interviewing the both of them side by
side and to have Dustin Poirier step in
to defend Eddie Alvarez who just kneed
him illegally in the face telling the
crowd don't boo this man like he was
literally upset and then it shook hands
there's something beautiful about that
and I think people to me people like the
animosity but they also really like the
fact when the animosity is squashed
after the fighting people hug it out
they really like that
[Applause]
[Music]